new spongebob still plays incredibly
well
um and then also the spin-offs like
we're talking we have camp coral coming
up we have a
patrick star spin-off we have a sandy
cheek spin off so we really are able to
build on that franchise because all of
the characters are so rich
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
before nickelodeon she was the cmo of
gimlet media
a spotify company she was the head of
marketing for hulu and prior to that was
the vp of
marketing at netflix we're excited to
hear about jimmy's impressive
experiences
and jenny please help my child stop
watching paw patrol
all the time around the clock y'all you
won
you won in this house paw patrol
everything thank you paw patrol
everything
good job jenny it's great to see you
thank you so much for being part of this
and uh anchoring us
on this wonderful morning thank you gary
and thank you roy i'm excited to be here
judy i'm actually going to use your
prior experience a little bit here to
bring value because
i'm reading twitter and trying to bring
as much value to everybody uh hashtag
marketing for the now if you have a
question
or an observation jenny talk to me about
audio obviously you know you being at
gimlet
uh and a pioneer there just two seconds
before we go into other matters
how do you see audio as a as a medium
where do you see it sitting obviously
you know roy's career
a lot you know was built on the back of
of radio we see this whole revolution of
podcasting
your two cents on it because i do think
you have a lot of uh important
observations
yeah i mean audio i i specifically took
the job at
um gimlet in order to learn audio
because i felt like it was an extremely
important touch point that was missed
during the day
that from that i used to call it that
well i still call it the id of the ear
strategy meaning once they leave the
couch how do you actually keep people
engaged in your brand
and the with alexa and with cars um
it just makes sense that you can
continue the story throughout
audio or whether that's in your ears and
it's also what i learned there it's just
how intimate really the audio
experiences
and i daniel x said something really i
think important when
when he acquired or his company acquired
gimlet obviously that just showed the
i think relevance um of where they were
putting their bets in regards to spotify
embedding in podcasts and also just
audio
storytelling and he said i can't believe
that the
ear or the eye is ten times more
expensive to buy than the ear
and he just felt like that was just
something to say this is actually an
extremely
important medium and so going to
going to there has actually helped me as
another step in my career to realize
okay let's just use an example for
blue's clues
and maybe your son's too old for that
but blue's clues
we're going to do story time with josh
and blue whereas
you could use it at nap time or you
could use it at bedtime and so just
trying to find these moments or like
okay the average drive is eight minutes
to
you know to a preschool um what do i do
with the kid in the car
and okay i've gotta watch listen to
story pirates because it's actually an
audio experience and then also i just
think
that people's parents including myself
of a six-year-old
especially during this time is really
trying to figure out how do i get my kid
off the ipad um and if i can get them
into more of
imagination through sound um
and actually creating worlds uh just i
think that's a big deal
yeah it's um so anyway that was longer
than my two cents or two seconds but i
do i think audio no no it's
but this is why we wanted you on and
this is why i wanted that question i
think your point when you
when you listen to some of the
incredible storytellers
of the 1970s uh
uh 1960s a lot of them refer to
sitting around the radio and listening
pre-tv
as an incredible driver for their
capacity for imagination and i think
why not replicate that i like that
roy when you all um
let's just talk about the pivot at
nickelodeon um
the cultural pivot not covet but with
george floyd and just totally
as a company what were some of the
internal discussions that you all had
as you started making the decision
because i feel like the corporations and
networks
there was kind of a staggering of which
companies and which media started doing
stuff and i felt like nickelodeon
was at the front of that what was where
was the decision
taught me through the decision to be one
of the first networks to make a bold
statement you can tell everybody what
the statement was with the 846.
yeah so um it wasn't hard at all and
that was i think we realized
very quickly what side we wanted to be
on and viacom
cbs came out with we're going to go dark
bob came out we're going to go dark for
8 minutes and 46 seconds and we said
who's participating and i have to give
credit to my boss brian robbins
didn't waste one second and said every
single network including nick jr
we did want to make a statement in
regards to where our support lies
we also truly truly believe that
education and enlightenment starts at a
very young age and that we have the
platform
to help start education and actually
foster those difficult conversations but
also help educate
and enlighten is the word that we like
to use so not just entertain but also
enlighten
and so it was a very simple decision uh
to go dark for eight minutes and 46
seconds
and so there was a couple different
spots there was a george floyd
um eight minutes and 46 seconds of a man
breathing
very very provocative that caused a lot
of um
a lot of conversation i will say on on
twitter
and social just about how to talk to
children and we also ran a kid's bill of
rights
um for eight minutes and 46 seconds so
that you have the right to be heard you
have the right to not be judged by the
color of your skin
you have the right to an education
that's turned into a much larger
campaign that we're running
but that also so there was it was a very
easy decision for us and
you know we believe you know all the
conversation
you know really opened up to say listen
you know we can actually talk to our
kids about more difficult things and it
allowed us to say listen
we're treating our children like with
kid gloves and we're also treating our
children
you know some people have different
experience and some kids live in fear
every day and we owe it to ourselves
for white children for black children to
open this conversation because racism
starts between the ages of two and four
and is embedded by age 12
and i think that we have them in the
sweet spot two to two to eleven
and so we cannot not help in this
situation and thus i think
then moving on to the juneteenth um
education that we did on that friday the
19th and then moving to alicia keys
we did another town hall for race kids
in unity um
that again you could watch on youtube if
you'd like it's a really incredible some
schools have picked it up um
to sort of teach and help start the
conversation but
but it was not hard for us at all and
we're continuing to i've
you know i've now made this an
initiative at nickelodeon where
you know we're putting money behind it
and i'm working with maverick carter
uh lebron's company and we're potent
hopefully working with them we're coming
up with ways we can work together to
develop content where they're short form
long form that this is not just a
campaign it's a sustained sustained
effort
that we continue to do both inside the
company and outside the company meaning
diversify our employees also as well as
our vendors and our outside
behind the camera in front of the camera
it's become a huge initiative for us and
we are definitely not slowing down
what's the biggest challenge for you
know
you and your executive team during covet
itself
when it first hit were you surprised by
any of the remote capabilities or did
did you feel like that was going to work
out you you have obviously worked in
some progressive companies in the past
um did did you yourself are you missing
like random interactions in the office
and travel or are you loving this like
a little bit of just like the insights
to leaders
during this time i i think it's
incredible how people have
creatively pivoted and sort of embraced
and solved a lot of
the creative adaptability if you will so
yes i think we all miss a little bit of
those hallway conversations and we miss
being able to you know
uh basically just knock on
walk in and talk to somebody but i think
what's been really great is we've been
able to
figure out how to do our work um even if
it comes down to
shoots like working with families to
shoot themselves and i think what we've
you know i think gary you and i talked a
little bit about this is sort of you
know the humanistic approach but the
stuff we're doing now is a lot less
polished and actually it's working
better for us because it's more human
and it's more about
actually families and them interacting
together so i think
that's been a really positive i'll say
the hardest thing for us is that not
being in production with new shows
so we're coming up we're not able to go
on set so
i think just keeping the content live uh
alive meaning that we're coming up with
shows like unfiltered
which is sort of a a game show that
we've that we do completely remotely we
have these danger for shorts we're doing
completely remote
um our marketing team is now developing
shows
we developed a spongebob fan favorite
special with the cast
um um you should go check it out it's
really fun
they're they're they're it's on youtube
but they're they're um
acting out famous scenes and it's really
great but so we're just coming up with
kind of creative ideas of what
programming could be because this might
last for a really long time
animation obviously yeah animation's in
a better spot than live action or
filming
do you feel like this is like what's
your
personal like any insights that i mean
are we looking at
i mean at this point it feels like the
rest of this year is definitely
not going to be the normal we knew prior
to this is there
is there programming concerns or because
i was going to just ask that
your animation chops do you feel like
you're sitting in a little bit of a
better spot than maybe some of your
contemporaries
i think we are studying i mean animation
takes a really long time to do so we're
having to speed up that
process a little bit but it's really
great we have some amazing shows like
casa grandes and loud house we have new
spongebob
we have it's pony we just renewed um uh
we've also just
you know greenlit a bunch of other
things that will happen come next summer
so we're i think we're in a very good
place there and i think we're also a
very good place that we've got an
incredible
youtube team that comes from full screen
uh
run by ashley kaplan that actually can
make incredible content
uh remotely really well so i think we're
in a really good spot but i would say
that for the yes the rest of this year
it is going to be challenging
um you know especially with what's
happening in california how it seems to
be getting worse at the moment but
we're cautiously optimistic that we'll
get a few things in and we're shooting
some things in vancouver
which is in a better space so i think
we're definitely going to have a good q4
um and so that's that's the thing i
think some people that are able to shoot
let's say
in europe might be at a better place but
if you can shoot in canada
right right right right it makes a lot
of sense right
as a as a parent how much does that
how much does that help you at your job
immensely another reason i say i take
each job i take for a reason one i took
audio i wanted to learn audio i took
this job one because i wanted to see if
like well one i love brian robbins i
think he's an incredible leader and i've
always wanted to work for him
um and i also just felt going being that
six years sort of on the digital side
what could
i bring to a linear channel that's
evolving in a digital
to help it make that move um but it's
also i would
would be lying if i said it doesn't i
can't i love it that i'm a hero at my
at that i that my six-year-old kid loves
what i
do um and also loves the stuff i work on
but i also have a focus group of one
here
uh that i can like bounce things off him
and i run trailers behind him and sit
you know
in front of him and so it's really
incredible and also it's really helped
open dialogue
another thing we were talking about
before with george floyd and racism
about
how i talk to my child um and it's
helped that figure out like how do i
talk to a kindergartner about racism and
he's going to be in first grade and how
do i talk to a six
six um like a sixth grader and it's very
different and so we're finding these
ways to figure out how do i make the
most impact with each age and so i do
have
one focus group of one here that's six
that i can bounce some things off of
um can a really important question for
me can you please
go to some sort of warehouse and steal
some rare teenage mutant ninja turtle
stuff for me so i can flip it on ebay
is that can we can we make that trade is
that is that allowed
no comment on this big part
we have some new ninja turtle stuff
coming up which i'm super excited about
is it you know one thing i'm very
fascinated i just heard new spongebob
new tmnt
right like it's kind of intriguing just
give a little glimpse into
this that i think a lot of viewers
wouldn't think about which is the
incredible opportunity that once a
franchise does hit that status
it really does play quote-unquote in
perpetuity like
you actually get to reboot restructure
think about spin off it is a real
gift to be able to play with these kind
of franchises it's also probably a huge
responsibility i'm sure there's a lot of
emotion
and politics behind it but it is
fascinating i mean just when
when i heard you say you know some new
spongebob i'm like
you know tmt like like it's it's
powerful to have these franchises
thoughts extremely powerful for us and
just also we have of the whole cp side
of this
so we know that you know that from a
plush perspective like like blues clues
right now is the number one toy in
walmart even during this
period of time i think people are
looking for some comfort but but we have
that whole side of where it actually
they can we can actually touch
um lives in a bunch of different areas
when we create these franchises but like
spongebob
yes new spongebob still plays incredibly
well
um and then also the spin-offs like
we're talking we have camp coral coming
up we have a
patrick star spin-off we have a sandy
cheek spinoff so we really are able to
build on that franchise because all of
the characters are so rich and then
working on the broadway play
um that we aired us also the spongebob
musical if you haven't seen that
it is so fun um but it's really
it really takes it into a different
realm but also just
as the same i thought that was super i
saw it i'm super clever like
that was a challenge a huge challenge
when i first heard it i'm like
yeah i thought it was extremely well
done no not by the way not
like i don't like i was pumped i was
like i'm an operator so i'm like ooh how
the hell would i operate that like where
are you going creatively with that and i
thought it was
super clever where were they i think the
biggest thing that was hard is that
spongebob doesn't know people exist
so he doesn't really understand the
world and so then you've got people
playing spongebob and patrick and so
there's that little
suspension of disbelief you have to
create and those characters have to
really embody
those characters under the sea in bikini
bottom and they did an incredible job
so jenny you did an incredible job here
thank you for your time hope you have a
great
great rest of the week and thank you for
your leadership and marketing community
thank you so much and thanks for having
me it's good to see all of you bye
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from feel free to
check it out